ma jumelle ma soeur d'avant monde
te souviens-tu de nos années
silencieuses à traverser la ville sans y
toucher à tisser autour de nous des
secrets dont on ne se défait pas
apporter ensemble notre anormalité à
être repoussé sans cesse par les autres
moquer de souviens-tu de cette sensation
de marcher seul dans la foule merci
Peggy bougarbal de prendre le temps avec
nous de te poser pour parler de ton
roman vengeresse quel a été le point de
départ de cette histoire ça a été mon
propre diagnostic d'autisme j'ai
également une sœur jumelle autiste et
en fait après ce diagnostic j'ai eu
besoin d'écrire d'écrire là dessus
comment tu travaillais sur ce roman là
j'étais complètement possédé en fait par
l'écriture à chaque fois que j'avais 20
minutes où je sois
j'écrivais donc pendant trois semaines
ça a été quasiment du non-stop dès que
j'avais un petit moment j'en oublie de
manger voilà ça a été très très rapide
aborder finalement l'autisme c'était
important pour toi quand j'ai eu ma
reconnaissance officielle même si je
suis diagnostiquée depuis très très
longtemps il y a eu quand même une phase
de colère parce que j'ai été un peu
euphorie qu'au moment du de la
reconnaissance je me suis dit bah très
bien je vais être intégrer tout le monde
va me comprendre parfaitement mais en
fait c'est pas le cas et j'ai eu besoin
d'expulser cette colère que j'avais et
puis de me remémorer aussi certaines
choses
plutôt difficiles dans mon enfance
plutôt que d'aller voir un psy je me
suis dit je vais écrire voilà ça je vais
gagner du temps je sors enfin dans la
nuit ou peut-être est-ce ma soeur
qu'importe la chasse à l'homme commence
des employés de 100 promesses ni
lendemain mes talons pilonnent
l'escalier je cours j'ai hâte mon ventre
à mal il faut guérir n'est-ce pas
quelqu'un voudra t-il de moi va-t-on me
trouver jolie je doute je me juge
durement dans le regard de l'autre
mais s'abandonner se taire enfin et ta
soeur jumelle elle a dû le lire ce livre
oui bah l'alu avant parution bien sûr
parce que son avis est important parce
que c'est quand même un livre qui est
très très dur alors c'est bien sûr c'est
une fiction comme j'expliquais nous
avons tué même si nous prenons le train
de temps à autre mais il y a quand même
quasiment toutes les scènes sont réelles
toutes les scènes ont existé je voulais
être sûr que
ça ne la perturbe pas voilà mais non
elle a aimé tel qu'il était et est-ce
que aujourd'hui comme le livre est
publié ce qu'on peut dire que la colère
est partie un peu un peu quand même je
suis voilà dans une phase plus
d'acceptation je suis pas encore dans
l'acceptation parce que c'est quand même
très très compliqué
la colère sera toujours là je pense
parce qu'elle est souvent réactivée par
des discriminations et les injustices
que subissent les personnes handicapées
alors la colère c'est pas forcément une
mauvaise chose contrairement
à la haine par exemple la colère ça peut
être un moteur après faut savoir bien
diriger sa colère de manière positive
parce que c'est possible aussi le juge
qui était cet homme qui prenait les
décisions sans nous enfermer dans un
bureau devant une pile de papier
écrasant notre avenir sous un coup de
tampon qu'avait-il compris entre les
lignes les doigts de ma sœur ça grippe
au mien à notre façon ses yeux me
retenaient au bord de l'abîme
tiens bon à défaut de guérir la
guérissable elle pensait mes plaies sans
elle je serai déjà morte de l'intérieur
nous avons enchaîné trois autres
familles d'accueil et de nouveau dure
déployer nos systèmes de défense élargir
le mur le bétonner nous avions de la
chance nous disait-on on ne nous
séparait pas fallait-il remercier et toi
qu'est-ce qui t'a poussé à écrire j'ai
appris à lire toute seule très très tôt
et vraiment ça a été une porte ouverte
j'ai eu cette chance d'avoir une maison
où il y avait une bibliothèque et ça m'a
permis de découvrir le monde moi je dis
toujours ça a été un pont vers les
autres et après de la lecture à découler
l'écriture voilà donc peut-être que si
j'avais pas été autiste je ne serais pas
écrivain aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
d'avoir partagé ce roman avec nous merci